good morning hey gets Tuesday so five
years ago when I was 40 I feel like I
was a fairly well informed person back
then but I did not know that the world's
deadliest infectious disease was
tuberculosis in fact on some level the
reason I'm so obsessed with tuberculosis
like to the extent that I'm on vacation
and yet still reading a book about Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle and his contributions
to tuberculosis research is because I
didn't know that tuberculosis was the
world's deadliest infectious disease
like what was so wrong with my ingestion
of information that I believed that
tuberculosis was like a 19th century
problem and I've seen this happen a lot
at parties and in conversations with
friends and every other time that I'm in
a social situation and I bring up
tuberculosis which is every time I'm in
a social situation people will be like
really I kind of thought that was a
problem of the past anyway I was talking
to a public health official recently
like a fancy person in the world of
global health and they said the problem
tuberculosis has is that it doesn't have
a constituency like illnesses that have
what he called a global constituency
tend to get much more attention and the
problems we pay attention to tend to be
the problems that we solve like look at
the other three great infectious
diseases of the 21st century so far the
21st century so far let's not jinx
ourselves we've got covid-19 which had a
global constituency from day one
powerful people and powerful countries
recognize that their lives and
communities were going to be upended by
covet and so there was an immediate
immediate expenditure of resources to be
like we we got to figure this out then
you've got HIV which primarily affected
marginalized people which made it harder
to build that Global Coalition right
like in the 1980s organizations like act
up emerged and through direct action and
tons and tons of activism were
eventually able to get the attention of
governments but like I think that it was
four or five years after HIV first
emerged in the United States that Ronald
Reagan the president into the United
States first mentioned it and then even
after all the work to discover and
disseminate new effective treatments
those treatments weren't available to
people in impoverished communities HIV
activists in the United States and
Europe and also in the global South came
together and worked together to build
that constituency as a result HIV deaths
over the last 20 years have dropped by
more than 50 percent and then lastly you
have malaria now organizations worked
incredibly hard to get malaria into the
center of Health conversations
especially in the early 2000s which is
when the malaria death rate finally
started to drop anyway what we're really
talking about when we talk about a
disease having a constituency is a
disease having a constituency that
includes people from Rich and Powerful
communities people who have access to
the megaphones of the social internet
and so on right because like
tuberculosis has a constituency over 10
million and people get sick every year
there are so many activists working so
incredibly hard to bring attention to
this crisis and yet I still didn't know
anything about it because I I wasn't
listening to those voices I I really
didn't even know how to listen to them
so five years ago when for instance the
young women who would eventually sue the
Indian government to make sure generic
but aquiline could be available for
production were engaging in activism I
didn't know about that activism and so I
would argue that actually what TB needed
was for people in the rich world to pay
attention and I feel like that is
beginning to happen not primarily
because of me although I will not shut
up about this believe me but because
people are beginning to understand that
the world's deadliest infectious disease
in 2023 is curable and the Cure isn't
just medicine it's also being able to
find cases and diagnose them quickly and
effectively so we know not just whether
they have TB but whether the TV they
have is resistant to certain antibiotics
and it's about preventing TB illness
once we've identified those cases by
giving their close contacts people who
live inside their household one month of
preventative treatment so that they
don't get sick with TB and it's about
making sure that every person who lives
with tuberculosis can access Curative
treatment and so I think there's a lot
of reasons why people like me weren't
paying attention to tuberculosis It
Kills Slowly instead of dramatically it
is a much bigger problem in low and
middle income countries than it is in
rich ones and most of all it's a disease
ultimately caused by crowded living
conditions by malnutrition and by other
symptoms of what is really the world's
leading cause of death
poverty all of that has meant that for
too long fighting tuberculosis has not
had the global constituency that it
needs but I hope that's starting to
change like when I was a teenager right
at the beginning of the internet there
was this IRL viral meme Andre the Giant
has a posse you'd see these stickers
everywhere and everywhere I saw them
they would bring me immense joy I love
the idea that Andre the Giant had a
posse that like there was a group of
people who were with Andre the Giant
that he would no longer be cast out and
marginalized for his size because Andre
the Giant has a posse now and that's
what I want for people living with
tuberculosis and the activists fighting
it is for tuberculosis fighters to have
a posse for the world especially the
rich world to say you are no longer
alone we will stand with you and we will
fight for you I genuinely think this
community helped lead a big step in that
direction last week and I am overwhelmed
with gratitude but it's step and we need
to make more of them Hank I'll see you
on Friday